[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE PROCOPIO: Well,
hello, everybody,
and welcome to Google
Cloud Next 2017.
It is great to have
you with us here today.
My name is Mike Procopio.
I'm a software engineer
on the Google Drive team,
and it's my great pleasure
to talk with you today
about a feature that we
recently launched called
Quick Access for Google Drive.
And we'll use Quick Access
as kind of a way to pivot
and learn a little bit about
how we use machine learning
at scale at Google
and also on Drive
and sort of take a
tour through some
of the challenges
associated with bringing
in an intelligent feature
like Quick Access to Drive.
A fairly casual
session here today.
There will be a demo,
time for Q&A later,
and so happy to stick around and
chat with anybody about those
things.
First slide here is a
preview of our talk.
Now, some say that agenda
slides are no longer allowed
or they're not in vogue anymore.
So this is definitely
not an agenda slide.
However, we may cover some of
the things listed in the bullet
points here today.
As you see, it will
be more than just
specifically about Quick Access.
We'll be talking a little bit
about intelligence features
in general and also take
kind of a closer look
at some of the production
engineering required
to pull off a feature like this
because it is a bit of a feat,
look at some of the
metrics and dashboards
that we use to
evaluate it, a few are
the challenges that
we've had along the way,
look at experiment frameworks
and a few case studies
that we went through in order
to get the feature up to snuff
and the quality high enough.
If things go well, we
might even have a demo.
And then finally, we'll have
time for some Q&A at the end.
So intelligence in Drive--
so as a kid growing
up in Florida,
my experience was
watching the space shuttle
launch, which was awesome.
And I quickly became aware
that space was hard, right?
And I think about
that a lot, especially
as we've done increasingly
intelligent things at Google.
And something that I
say to myself often
is that intelligence is hard.
Now, that doesn't mean
that it's a miracle.
It can be done.
But these things are often
unforgiving and complicated.
Fundamentals of machine
learning are also complicated.
Like, space flight machine
learning is easily misapplied.
It's very easy to think
that you're actually helping
the user when you are not.
20 years ago, I can remember
an assistive experience
in a productivity
suite wherein I
would be starting
to type a letter,
and then an assistant
would try and help me
with writing a letter.
That's an example of an
earlier kind of experience.
But yet, I've got
nothing but love
for the early days of
assistive features because
of launch and
iterate, and that's
we have to start somewhere.
Similarly, with Quick Access and
intelligent features at Google.
So doing easy things
with machine learning,
as we've seen in the
past decades, is easy.
Doing useful things is
a little bit harder.
And so how do we get there?
Well, we start small but real.
We measure.
We're rigorous.
And we always make sure
that we're helping.
Having a compelling
UX very important.
And at last, we can launch
and iterate and never lose
sight of what we're here
for, which is the user.
Focusing on the user and
increasingly focusing
on the business is
part of our DNA.
We're here to help people
do their job better,
not just build some
shiny, fancy thing.
We're here to help the business
run better and to create value.
And that means more
and more tackling
exceptionally
difficult problems,
making our lives more
challenging and more difficult,
if you will, in the
name of the user
in order to provide
experiences that
help them do their job
better and to provide value
to the business.
This is a pretty extraordinary
opportunity if you look at it.
An organization's
entire knowledge
is stored in Drive in the cloud.
It's a massive opportunity
to do intelligent things.
The data is there.
And that relates to
one of our goals,
which is to increasingly
evolve Drive
into a center for knowledge
exchange for your business.
And that is quite a lofty goal.
It's more of a
mission or a vision,
and how do we get there?
Once again, we return
to our first principles,
which is launch and iterate,
and always focus on the user.
Today we launched Quick
Access for Team Drives,
and later last year, we launched
Quick Access for enterprises
in the My Drive space
outside of Team Drives.
That's our first big
feature in this space.
And if you think about
it, it represents a launch
and iteration of its own.
Let's take a quick
look at Quick Access.
So fundamentally, the
value and the premise
of what Quick Access
is trying to do
is very prominently display
documents to the user
that they're likely
to want to open.
These could be documents
they know about.
They could be documents
that they don't know about.
We want to ultimately allow
them to make better business
decisions, showing
them relevant documents
to help them make the
best decisions they can,
adding value to the business.
And as a secondary goal-- and
this one's a little bit easier
to measure--
we ultimately want
to save users time.
And our early data show
that Quick Access, when
you open Drive and your
intent is to actually open
a file, when you
use Quick Access,
you get to your file 50% faster.
That's because
regardless of whether you
have folders and are an
organizer, if you will, or have
never created a folder in a
storage system in your life
and rely on search,
Quick Access is
going to show you the most
critical files that you're
most likely to open at
that period of time.
And our data show that
we've been fortunate to have
a lot of success here.
A quick tour of what
we're talking about.
So Quick Access is
available on all platforms.
And for Drive, that's
mobile, and web, Mac and PC.
Quick Access not available
on the sync client
but on both iOS and Android.
Here's what it looks
like on Android.
And importantly,
as of today, this
is now rolling out to
Team Drives as well,
and that's a screenshot
on the right.
Similarly for iOS, both
My Drive and Team Drives.
And also rolling out
over the next two weeks,
we have Quick
Access for the web.
And we'll actually be
demoing that today.
And there's a live demo
downstairs as well,
I believe, in here
and/or in Moscone,
also rolling out
for Team Drives.
So this is fairly
important for us.
It's not something
you want to build
for an individual platform.
Platform parity is important.
We want to make sure when we
build the feature that it works
both for our consumers
and their My Drive,
but increasingly in enterprises
and the recently announced
this morning Team Drives, and
that is a key goal of ours.
Kind of an early look at some
of the impact that we've had,
we're fortunate to have
success with this feature.
One of the happy thoughts here
is that intelligence works.
We can do useful things with
machine learning beyond just
toy problems, right?
We always have a baseline
that we evaluate our approach
against, and our data show that
we are beating the baseline,
in this case, MRU or
Most Recently Used,
by a statistically significant
amount in all cases.
So that's great.
We've also seen that
Quick Access saves users
time, reduces time to open
a document by 50% assuming
you're going to Drive
to open a document.
And then more
subtly, Quick Access
has really proven
out our machine
learning infrastructure
here on Drive
and given us a solid
platform and framing
to iterate more quickly to do
other features, because there
so much that goes
behind it, including
all of the production,
engineering, and all
of the measurement rigor,
and the dashboards,
and even some of
the cultural mindset
that we'll dive into
here in a moment.
Let's take a look at
the production system.
So this is a large-scale
production system.
And one of the
early findings here
is that a machine
learning project is not
just like we're going to
go to machine learning.
We don't do it in a vacuum.
Instead, it exists as part of a
much larger production system.
And when you're talking about
the recently announced 800
million monthly active
people who used Drive,
thousands of businesses
across all of the platforms
that we've just seen, this is a
large-scale production system.
We have to have rigor
around the servers, all
the data processing pipelines.
Even the UX must be very
carefully thought of.
Dozens of servers
are involved, and it
is a Google-scale project
end to end, which means
it's hard but very exciting.
It takes a lot of
infrastructure to get here.
Some examples are on the right,
and I just kind of put together
this list.
So it's the machine learning
frameworks and tool kits
that you would expect--
Google Brain; DistBelief, which
is our internal tool kit that
we use right now; increasingly
in the future, TensorFlow,
which is our open source
machine learning framework;
all of the data processing,
large-scale analytics that we
use with parallel processing
on the back via MapReduce,
which our core distributed
computational technology;
an experiment framework to be
able to evaluate hypotheses
to figure out whether you're
actually improving the system;
the ability to query
large-scale data;
all the stuff you need to stand
up servers and multiple data
centers--
load balancing, deployment,
APIs and the remote procedure
calls that you make in between
them; all of the dashboard
visualizations; and
finally, a framework
to be able to do statistics well
because doing statistics well,
it turns out to
be very difficult.
Here's an architecture diagram.
We won't go too
deeply into this,
but the general idea
here is that to be
able to predict
something like this,
you'll find that there
are a lot of pieces here.
In this case, there's the
offline model training.
We're training up
a neural network.
That's an offline process
that takes one or two days.
We'll see that here in a moment.
And then the evaluation is
done online or in real time
when a client makes
a call to generate
the most probable documents
that you want to show.
But on top of this is
all of the metrics,
and the logging,
and the dashboards,
and the experiment framework.
And then very critically, there
is a dedicated service and team
that is actually responsible
for aggregating and anonymizing
and generating the
data that is ultimately
used to train models and indeed
extract features that are used
when we're making predictions.
That's Activity
service in the middle.
So it turns out the actual
science, the machine learning
aspect of it, is one
comparatively small part
of a much larger
production system.
It's an exciting
result, but it means
we have to really
focus on what we
call the [? prodeng ?] as well.
So one thing we'll do today is
learn about the actual machine
learning that we do here at
Google, and in particular,
for this.
Machine learning in general
requires three broad things--
features, data, and algorithms.
So features are
basically the signals
that you can use to
kind of separate data
and to make predictions.
In other domains, they're
called inputs or predictors.
Multiple features together,
these are signals extracted,
from this case, documents.
Multiple features together
form a feature vector
where a feature vector can have
a lot of different features--
in this case, tens of thousands
in this particular project.
Some of those
features are raw data.
Some of them are engineered.
They're functions
of other features.
We apply certain
transformations.
In general, we do fairly
minimal post-processing, not too
much scaling or
anything like that.
The neural networks are very
adaptive to kind of take
anything that you
want to throw at them.
And some examples of features
that we would use here
include per document
counts of the number
of times a document is
opened, when it was last open,
these kinds of things.
The time or the temporal
aspect turns out
to be a very predictive
and powerful feature.
And so we encode
this as periodicity.
And what that means is if you
open a document-- and this is
an example of a feature that
we found to be very compelling.
If you open a document
every Saturday morning,
maybe your household budget
at 8:00 AM over your coffee,
and you do that every
Saturday at 8:00 AM,
well, that is actually
very strongly predictive
of you probably doing that
next Saturday as well.
Great opportunity
to save you time
so you don't have to drill down
into your folders or search.
So if we can encode
that correctly
with a little bit of
feature engineering,
we have on our hands a
very powerful feature,
which overall is part of the
impact of the intelligence
here.
So we also have user models.
We understand a little bit
about the user and the things
that they do, their
actual behaviors,
not conditioned or on an
aspect of any specific document
but about the user themselves.
And those turn out to be
useful signals for the model.
And then finally,
in the future--
and we'll nudge against
this here shortly--
but there's a lot
that we can do here
that requires a little
bit deeper understanding
beyond just documents, but
for example, the user's
social graph.
For example, if my boss has
been commenting on a file
that I'm working
on is probably more
impactful to me than somebody
further in my network.
So we want to capture
this mathematically
in terms of the statistics
and the model prediction
and factor them in.
So the features are ultimately
extracted on raw data.
That is, in this case, produced
from an existing service
at Google called
Activity Service, which
receives and records events
on a per document level, which
for the scale that we operate
at at Google, is no small feat--
things like when the document
was created and shared, opened,
when it was commented on, all of
the things that are available,
metadata about the document
that we want to encode.
There's also users stats,
basically the user model that
can be computed online,
attributes about the user,
and then in the future,
other deeper understanding
around the social graph.
So per document
activity and online user
modeling and processing
is the fundamental source
of most of this data.
And at last, we come
up with the algorithm,
which has historically
been, as a machine learning
practitioner, one of my
favorite things to talk about,
except at Google, it's
just really boring
now because we just
say, OK, everything's
a deep neural network, right?
And once upon a
time, neural nets
were very much not
in vogue position
to other things you may have
heard about, like support
vector machines, large ensembles
of simple linear classifiers,
for example.
But with the advent of back
propagation for training,
they've sort of come into vogue.
And as it turns out, the
only thing that matters
is how well the actual
algorithm does in practice.
And what we find is
that neural networks
are extremely
capable in this space
for a large variety of
problems-- searching,
ranking, prediction, image
classification, for example.
And they are very robust to
large numbers of features,
like in the tens of
thousands of features.
If you did that for like
a support vector machine
where the training complexity
is a function of the number
of features, well, the model
might not ever converge
and you'd have not
effective classifier.
So neural nets kind
of take dimensionality
out of the question,
which is very exciting.
And internally,
we use DistBelief,
which is described in the
literature internal to Google.
But soon, we'll be
moving to TensorFlow,
which is the open
source machine learning
tool kit that's very powerful.
It's great.
It means that people
outside of Google
can use the exact
same technologies
that we use for
prediction here, including
for our searching and
ranking tasks across Google.
So neural networks
can be wide or deep.
Ours are not particularly deep.
I think there's
five hidden layers
between the inputs for each
feature, and then the outputs.
And I think on the order of
80 nodes per hidden layer.
So it's a fairly wide,
not super deep neural net,
which is not at all uncommon.
OK, this is a fairly technical
talk, and you wanted details.
This is a quick slide to
talk about specific details
that we actually use.
As we've seen, this is modeled
as a neural net trained
with what we do typically
now with conventional back
propagation.
And training uses asynchronous
stochastic gradient descent
in particular, as described
in the literature.
We use 40,000
features right now.
That's a lot of features.
We probably don't
need that many.
We suspect we can
do just as well
with our predictions for Quick
Access with fewer features.
Feature selection
is a little bit
difficult for a neural network,
as is interpreting the model,
but we're going to
work towards that.
This is set up as ultimately
a two-class classification
problem.
The probability
that you're going
to open this document right
now or not that, right,
and on a continuous
output, which
is the output of the neural net,
and separate out the boundary
and rank as desired.
And so you need positive
training examples of things
that the user has opened in the
past and then negative training
examples of things that
the user has not opened.
So that forms the basis
of our classification.
Training is a very large task.
We have a lot of features.
It may take one or two
days for the actual model--
and we're generating one model--
to evolve and to converge.
And there's lots of
cross-validation and creating
multiple replicas.
And it's a very
computationally intensive task
distributed across,
I think, a couple
of hundred individual
processors,
workers in this case.
So this is a fairly
large endeavor.
But of course, we do
all of that work, which
is basically pre-computation.
Why?
So we can evaluate
quickly in real time.
When a user opens up and
when we open up Drive,
we see Quick Access.
That is a real-time request to
get the most probable documents
for the user in that moment
based on the state of all
of their documents.
And that means we're extracting
the features in real time.
And we can do that on the
order of 100 milliseconds
in the common case.
So we do all that
work training to be
able to come up with a very
quickly evaluated model, which
is one of the benefits of
a neural network model.
So good.
So taking a step back
from the details,
I wanted to get a little
bit philosophical.
I've been thinking
about this a lot.
One of my favorite
things about Google
is this increasing machine
learning-aware culture
that we have here.
And now when I first
started, it was
we'd use machine learning
in like Search, for example,
but it did not have
this cultural presence
that it does now.
Times were different.
And It's what I
went to school for.
So to see it kind of take
hold is very exciting.
But it's not just individual
engineering competencies.
It's everything that it takes
to land a feature like this
that we have a Google.
So the concept of having
privacy front and center,
and thinking about that, and
talking candidly about it,
and having privacy experts who
are aware of common concerns
that we could have--
a very privacy-centric
culture is
critical to doing
this project properly.
Cloud expertise, this
is a cloud project.
We're not operating on
local data on a filer.
So we need to be very good about
processing data in the cloud
and doing that in
a thoughtful way.
And it takes leadership
buy-in, right?
This is not just an
individual engineer's project.
This is a large endeavor,
the whole concept
of intelligence features
and assisting the user.
Very important to have
leadership buy-in, all
the way down from team leads
to engineering managers
to executives, right, to
kind of transform the culture
and to support a
project like this,
because it's fairly
expensive in terms
of how many people
need to support it
and the research
that we've done.
Of course, we've seen all
the system's infrastructure
that's required.
Product managers need to
be bought into the value
proposition to
the users and need
to be shown that we're
actually helping users.
There needs to be an
enterprise focus increasingly
because that's where we
see most of the impact
from features like this.
We need to do the UI
and the UX very well
because we can do
harm here, right,
if we surface a
great feature that
doesn't have a compelling UX.
We'll see some screenshots
of this here shortly.
And just in general,
broader culture
around learning and
intelligence, and having
classes that people
can take just because,
and learning about statistics
and being able to increasingly
just think, how can we do
this kind of naive thing maybe
a little more intelligently?
So I've really come to
appreciate the increasing
machine learning
culture at Google,
and I have seen
that it is really
required to be able to pull
off a feature like this.
So we've seen how
we can use machine
learning to generate models.
One of the most important
things that we can do
is measure our success.
Measurement is critical
for any project like this.
My dad used to tell me,
measure twice, cut once.
I didn't always obey that,
but I definitely do now.
Our approach is
basically threefold.
We define rigorous metrics
that are meaningful.
These are numbers
that you can actually
use, optimize a model to.
It's a very mathematical
thing, right--
a loss function or an
optimization function.
So we define these
summary metrics ultimately
to capture what we think the
user cares about, right--
how often we're
predicting the right sort
of thing, how often
they're engaging
with Quick Access in general.
They have to be
carefully defined.
And then you can't
just report a number.
You need to do proper
statistics around them.
And if you're comparing
different sorts of approaches
in an experimental
fashion, you need
to be able to compute
confidence intervals on the test
group versus the control
group to figure out if you've
actually helped or hurt.
And then finally,
it's very important
to have a sensible baseline.
In this case, we're going to
predict your most recently
used documents as a baseline,
things you most recently opened
or edited.
And we want to do
better than that.
If we're not doing
better than our baseline,
we're not really doing an
intelligent, impactful thing.
Specific metrics that we
use, that we care about--
and they all capture
different things.
First, the astute viewer will
note that all are going upwards
and towards the right.
That's a very good thing.
I wouldn't call them
fully hockey stick,
but they're trending in
the correct direction.
That's not an accident.
We want to rigorously improve
this continually, and only
through doing that will
we land at a useful thing.
Examples of the three
metrics we use--
hit rate measures the actual
percentage of the time
that Quick Access
was correctly used
to predict the doc
that the user wants--
in other words, the
percentage of the time
that the user found their
document through Quick
Access, which is subtly
different than accuracy, which
is more the
percentage of the time
that Quick Access predicted
the document that the user
ultimately did open.
See the nuance there?
And then finally,
click-through rate,
which is more a measure
of engagement with the UI
feature itself.
What percentage of
the time are the users
actually using Quick Access
when Quick Access is available?
These don't paint the
identical picture.
It is possible to optimize for
one of these but not the other.
And now we have
a problem, right?
So we consider all three
of these metrics together
and we want to see
them improve together
having seen firsthand that it's
possible to improve one and not
the other.
Similarly, we have
production metrics.
There's a lot of dependencies.
This is not a science project.
We are constantly monitoring
the health of what
we consider to be a service.
The three key things here
are QPS, Queries Per Second;
latency--
in other words, how
fast are we doing
this where fast is a
very important thing
to do things in--
as well as error rate.
We want this to be a reliable,
error-free experience.
Examples of what this looks
like, and we track them.
QPS is on the left.
You can see kind of
our natural cycle.
We do have a daily cycle.
There is peak traffic at a
specific time during the day.
The challenge of any
production system
is coping with peak load,
where in general, we
try and smooth things out
to the extent possible.
We've done some load testing.
And of course, there's
organic platform growth.
We're rolling out
to other platforms.
And additional users are
coming to those platforms,
and that will be
reflected in that.
Similarly, we always
compare QPS with latency
because there is a
relationship here,
that the more you throw at
your servers, the more queries,
on average, the slower things
are going to get, especially
if you have to queue requests or
there's other capacity issues.
We've made some major
strides with our latency.
And we look at things like
latency in the average case,
but how about latency
like in the worst case?
Maybe you have a
particularly large corpus
or a large number of files.
So we never look at these
numbers in isolation.
We talk about things like
median latency and latency
at the 95th percentile,
for example.
So we've done some
optimizations here--
launch and iterate, right?
Always optimizing,
finding the bottleneck.
Parallelization solves
a lot of problems
as well as just throwing
more hardware at things.
If you're under provisions and
slow, well, maybe add a few
more tasks or instances
of the server that
can receive these requests.
Pivoting to dashboards, this
is one of my favorite aspects
about this project.
It would be very easy to
do something like this
and have ad hoc
analyses on [? one ?]
running one-off queries
by one or two people.
But instead, we've
institutionalized the things
that we care about,
and we've done that
through a dashboard, which
is critical infrastructure
in its own right.
They show real-time
results of the system.
They show the results
of the experiments
that we're trying to do.
Here, we've scrubbed the numbers
because they're sensitive,
but you can see our
three key metrics
are there, but also the
confidence intervals and then
the comparison
with our baseline.
So it helps us to kind of
get cultural knowledge around
how well we're doing.
And of course, they're
very transparent.
Everything is transparent here.
And critically,
this is always based
on heavily aggregated,
anonymized summary statistics
data--
very critical for dashboards.
Other examples from
the dashboards,
we have our historical
primary metrics over time,
both in graph time series format
and in tabular format, as well
as how much time
we've saved the user.
That's very important to us.
And we can actually chart
that as kind of an area
under the curve sort of a thing.
Positional statistics count,
this is an interesting finding.
We find that the majority of
impact that comes from this
is going to be in the
first n predictions, right?
And so if all of the
benefit of your feature
comes from predicting
just three things
and you're getting it
right so much that you
don't need to predict
the other things, well--
the other seven things or
have an extended carousel,
you can imagine that that's
important for UI and UX.
In particular,
maybe our carousel
doesn't need to
have 10 items in it
if we're always or usually
right at the first three or five
things.
So these dashboards,
this data feeds back
into a number of decisions.
Three challenges that
were particularly--
and by "challenging," I don't
mean unpleasant or difficult.
I mean intriguing and
very engaging, right?
It's the challenging stuff
that makes for a an exciting
engineering day.
Privacy is perhaps our
most critical challenge,
but it's also built
into our culture.
And so it's this wonderful
dialogue that we continually
have about every time we
code or do a design review,
we're constantly poking
holes in things to say,
could that data leak, or do we
need to aggregate that data?
And the answer is yes.
Do we need to have you
anonymize this data?
We're very careful with log
sources, these sorts of things.
We think about this
cross-functionally, not just
engineers, not just leaders,
but product managers and program
managers.
It's always on our mind.
And importantly,
there are experts
who see these things all
day everyday and understand
the common modes
or areas of concern
that we might have
around privacy,
both in different
usage modalities--
for example, enterprise
versus consumer users outside
of the enterprise.
It's a passion, and
it's almost an--
it is an interesting
problem in its own right.
We understand that we have
very important constraints
that we have on the data.
We need to do right by the user,
and we need to be very careful.
And so how can we
make experiments
around hypotheses based
on aggregated data?
How can we still
build a useful system
with these very careful
controls in place?
It's a science problem
in its own right.
So a couple of specific things.
We don't allow raw
access on the engineers
to any kind of user data.
We don't allow user tracking.
Instead, we work with anonymized
data and aggregated summary
statistics.
And as noted, enterprise
data is specifically not
available for use in most cases.
Another challenge is the
challenge around data quality.
So we have an existing
server that was first built
to generate document data--
and this is a fairly
old screenshot--
but to generate activity
data for a given
document in the Drive
clients, in the UIs.
And that is a very different
task than generating data
that's going to be used by
a machine learning system
for a neural network
that's saying,
feed me features all the time.
So that's actually
one of our challenges
is it's very fortunate that
we have this infrastructure,
but it's a new use case
for an existing service.
That means there might
be holes in the data
or that we may need to
process some of the data more.
Not all the things
that we need are there.
And of course,
ultimately, we just
hooked up a very
large-scale system
to an existing server
that needs to be
very carefully provisioned
for that around rollout.
So data quality,
availability, server
load is one of these kind of
classic production engineering
challenges that we have.
And then finally, pivoting
towards UI and UX,
it is not easy to
create a useful UI here.
And part of the challenge is
is that as your predictions get
better and better, you may
be able to finally land
a different UI.
You may be able to have
a more prominent UI.
Maybe it's shown all the time
only once your predictions
get good enough.
At first, we
weren't sure, right?
And we would pop up, as you
see on the left, a modal dialog
only when our predictions were
above a very high confidence,
well, because they
weren't always.
We hadn't launched and we
hadn't iterated enough.
But over time, we
got we got better.
And we are in an era of where
we have user UX design and UX
research.
And just like we run
experiments on our hypotheses
for ideas around features,
for our intelligence,
so too do we do research
around how a given UI looks.
So we have a very strong
culture on prototype
and doing user
studies and iterating.
And at last, we
ended up on the UI
that you can see here today
on your mobile device,
on iOS or Android, which
is the one on the right.
And even then, we're iterating,
as you'll see in a few more
screenshots, to where--
we'll talk about that-- to a
more different design showing
larger thumbnails.
Experiments are a
critical part of the way
that we are able to
improve the overall system.
In general, it is very easy
to say, hey, you have an idea.
Let's make a new feature
and put it out there.
And you have no way to
know if it helped it.
Certainly, you could
drum up a use case
that shows, hey, look at this.
I did this thing and now this
new thing is being predicted,
and it's perfect.
But maybe you made it
worse for everybody.
And in fact, you probably did
because improving a system
like this is not
a trivial thing.
And features that you think may
be useful for you may not be.
And yet, this kind of
creative hypothesis generation
is at the center of how we can
potentially improve things.
This is science, basically.
It's a science experiment.
So we have a very rigorous
kind of cultural use
of the experiment
framework, which
is part of our common
infrastructure at Google.
So we can rigorously
test the hypothesis
and figure out whether we're
actually improving or hurting.
And over time, the
model accuracy improves
and we hope that user
adoption does as well.
A few case studies here
to look at how this works.
We encode how recently an
item is opened or edited,
and we're trying to figure out
how best to represent that.
In other words,
we're actually trying
to figure out how to engineer
the raw data into a feature
that the neural network
will most effectively be
able to use,
optimizing ultimately
for your summary metrics.
So the hypothesis here is that
opening or editing something
within one or five
or 10 minutes,
basically showing a histogram
of counts of the number of times
it was done there,
could be useful,
but there's so many
free parameters here--
basically, the bucket
size of the histogram,
which is a very common
way to represent
feature vectors for machine
learning algorithms.
So we run an experiment,
right, multiple experiments
to figure out, what
will the model best
be able to predict with?
And ultimately, we found that
encoding a feature in bucket
size that captures the fact
that a file has been acted on
at one in five minute
intervals was impactful.
And the result is
we correctly chose
the histogram of
bucketing size to be
able to give our model
the effective feature
representation to be able
to make good predictions.
You can see how
nuanced this is, right?
We wouldn't be able to
just do this arbitrarily,
and it was only through
statistically significant
experiments that we can find
that, hey, we did well here.
Another case study is
using Calendar data.
So there's a magic moment
here, which is basically,
you have a meeting
coming up and somebody's
attached an attachment
to the meeting, something
that you need to go over
ahead of the meeting
or during the meeting.
So you don't want to be
chatting links to the thing.
Everybody needs to have
the agenda pulled up
on their document or
whatever on their laptop.
And the idea is
that, hey, we think
we can do a cool
thing here, but we
have a little bit of humility to
know that maybe it's not always
the right thing.
And we also need to understand
we have to figure out
when to show this, right?
So if I show you
a document that is
going to be at a meeting
two weeks from now,
that's not going
to be impactful.
That might actually hurt
our overall statistics,
the overall metrics.
Maybe we could have
predicted something
better in that first
slot, for example.
So we're trying
to optimize here.
So what was our finding?
We were able to find values
for when to show a calendar
attachment in the first
slot that overall had
an improvement to
our metrics and that
had an acceptable click-through
rate for that prediction.
And the hope is to be able to
do a demo of that here now.
Ah, demo time, OK.
So my friends always ask
me, why do you do live demos
in talks like this?
It's because I like
to live dangerously,
said with an English accent
that I'm not able to do.
And then my boss, who's
in the room, always ask,
what could possibly go wrong?
And that's just something
that we say here.
So nonetheless, we're going to
do a demo today to kind of show
what Quick Access looks like
on web, which is, again,
rolling out in the
next couple of weeks,
and also look at what
Quick Access looks
like for Team Drives.
And we'll use the calendar
attachment as our approach.
So it looks like we've
got the demo up there.
So in this demo, there
are two accounts.
There is somebody,
if I move over here,
in the Ink 42, which
is the test domain.
It's a domain that we have here
at Next, which is basically
modeling an enterprise.
And you can see I have Quick
Access predictions here.
I will Shift-Reload
and see what we get.
People are using this,
so the predictions are--
so somebody just created
some meeting notes.
Great, so that's showing up.
So there is an
existing appointment
on this person's calendar,
a presentation on ML.
That's right here.
And that appointment is shared
with this second account, which
is in this window right here.
And so the idea is that
we're going to come here,
and this is the user that's
not in that enterprise.
This is actually
a personal user.
And they will make an attachment
to the calendar appointment
shared between the two users.
In this case, I'll click
on this, that you're
invited to the reunion.
Maybe they've got a little
family reunion thing going on.
Save it.
We'll send out updates.
So that's going to write and
propagate into all the systems.
So if I come back into
Drive for this user
now that was in the domain
that has a shared calendar
appointment that just had
an attachment added to it,
and they happened to
go to their Drive,
the expectation is is that they
will see that show up there.
There it is, yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
Oh, you all.
All right, I'll keep
doing live demos
as long as they keep
working every time.
OK, right.
So that's great.
There are other things.
I could remove it.
It would show up if I
removed access for this user.
Everything is live
and connected.
So if I removed access, it would
remove itself automatically
from that list.
While we're here,
we can drill in
and take a look at
what Quick Access looks
like for Team Drives.
There's a sales team
test Team Drive here.
You can see that we actually
can make Quick Access document
predictions within the
context of a Team Drive--
very enterprise-focused.
And that's rolling out
in the next few weeks.
Of course, Team Drives
just launched today.
We are finding early results
that show very compelling data
that these predictions
are especially
useful in the context
of Team Drives.
The problem is it seems very
applicable to machine learning.
So we're able to have pretty
high results and statistics
on our predictions here.
So that's super exciting,
and also very motivating
to continue to iterate here.
So that's it for the demo.
We have a few more slides
to kind of wrap up and talk
about future direction
that we can switch back
to here when you have a chance.
Thank you.
Future directions-- Quick
Access is only the beginning.
And as we've had
success with this,
it's very encouraging to
have these early successes,
but we have a lot more
that we want to do.
So here's an idea of what we can
do, both with Quick Access but
and beyond.
Of course, at Google, we have
a saying "Fast everybody's
favorite feature."
You have to be fast.
It's Quick Access.
You don't want to wait
two or three seconds
for your documents to show up.
You want to wait 200 or 300
milliseconds for your documents
to show up.
So there are things
that we can do here.
We can have a cache where
we maintain the predictions.
And then when the predictions
might change from the back ends
because the underlying
data changed,
we can push basically a
notification in the cache that
says, you need a refresh.
We'll do the pulling
offline, and then we
can answer this in tens of
milliseconds, for example.
Caching, of course,
known to be the solution
to all known computer
science problems, but also
the cause of all known
bugs in production systems.
So we have to be careful
with our caching.
And we'll probably have an
experiment with the cache
on or off.
The hope is is that faster
results will improve accuracy,
but we don't know that.
We certainly hope it does.
Also, client/server
protocol optimizations,
always leaning out
the message size,
back and forth, leaning
out the number of server
calls that it takes to
actually get this data.
We want increased
quality as well.
In general, we can make small
tweaks to the model parameters
and run our
experiments, but we feel
right now that the
majority of the larger
increases within the context
of this specific Quick Access
feature would come from
using new signals, signals
from across G Suite--
so for example,
the social graph, weighting
things by people who
are in your network, your
professional network, closer,
weighting those more heavily;
and then also understanding
maybe even the
organization hierarchy.
And then there's
also the concept
of topical information
about a document,
wherein you're probably,
in a general basis,
more interested in documents
that are about things
that you have previously
read, in general.
So we can extract a
topic model and then
do computations as well.
So new signals, we
hypothesize, will greatly
increase the quality of the
Quick Access predictions
even further beyond the
baseline than it is now.
Of course, this is an
infrastructure project.
We are always having
infrastructure efforts.
We're improving our servers.
We're improving reliability.
We're adding capacity.
We're migrating, in this
case, to TensorFlow,
which is Google's open source,
new generation machine learning
tool kit.
And then finally,
new features-- and by
"features," I don't mean machine
learning features in the sense.
I mean user experiences.
So we've just launched
Team Drives today.
It represents a fairly
substantial one-
to two-year-long effort.
There's a lot of
opportunity here.
We think that there's so much
value around intelligence
and assistive UIs in the
enterprise space, especially
in the Team space,
that we've already
started envisioning a
lot of impactful features
here beyond just things
like document prediction.
Deeper understanding and
assistance with content
and file organization.
Some people have a very
carefully curated file
hierarchy, a folder
hierarchy, but not everybody.
In fact, it's not even
necessarily that common.
And curating data takes a
lot of our brain cycles.
We feel that we can probably
automate this task pretty well,
but that's just an example
of another feature that's
somewhat different
than Quick Access
and yet would have the exact
same kind of approach, right,
around the production
infrastructure,
the feature generation, the
use of a neural net perhaps,
and then the dashboards
and measurement rigor.
And then finally, if you've
seen Quick Access here,
you've seen that the little
carousel was kind of placed
in at the top of the UI.
The predictions are good enough
and we're saving enough time
that we feel like
we're able to give
a fairly high, prominent UI
experience with the prediction
carousel.
However, we're starting to
envision other things here
around people in
teams that are harder
to fit into existing UIs.
At some point, we've kind
of shoehorned everything in.
So we're starting to imagine a
completely different experience
that kind of moves us past
a raw listing of files
and more towards kind of a
more holistic intelligence
and assistive experience.
So that's coming soon.
Some key takeaways--
to do well here,
everything has to
go right, right?
You have to get the correct
signals for your model.
You have to train
the model correctly.
You have to optimize the
model to the correct metrics.
That's a mathematical process.
You have to optimize for that.
You need good
infrastructure that
can scale to 800 million
users across four or five
different platforms,
hammering this endpoint,
requesting their predictions.
You need a beautiful and
very usable user experience,
or otherwise, you're going
to get in the user's way.
It all has to be
super fast, and you
have to continually improve with
new features and new signals
and do that in a principled
way using experiments.
And if you do all of those
things-- and it is an "and"--
then what we have found
with this dedication,
we can slowly improve the
quality of our predictions
to where we're doing a useful
thing and it's no longer a toy.
And that is what we've
launched here today.
And we think it's quite magical,
an intelligence feature that
delivers real value to the
user and to the business.
And then finally, I wanted to
leave us with some key ideas
here.
Intelligence features like
Quick Access add value
to the business.
They enable users to
make better decisions.
And we've seen that
it saves them time.
We've seen that I like to say
that intelligence is hard,
and yet, it can be done with
a very rigorous approach.
You need a lot of
infrastructure and expertise,
and also a culture around
leadership and product vision,
and a dedication to
launching and iterating
continuous improvement, the
experiment framework and rigor.
We've seen that a
compelling UX is critical.
I can dream up a lot
of very fancy things
that a neural network can
predict and have no idea how
to surface them in
the UI, other things
that we could possibly
predict, and just I
wouldn't know how to do that.
Or you could do that.
It would be modal, and now
you're interrupting the user.
A compelling UX is
critical regardless
of how good your
neural network accuracy
or area under the curve is.
These things are
very closely related.
And then finally, Quick Access
is a large-scale infrastructure
project.
It's very much about
production engineering.
It's not just about machine
learning or even TensorFlow
or the machine
learning tool kits.
It's all the servers.
And then at last,
it's something that's
truly native to the cloud.
Having the data in the
cloud is how we can do this.
It's not something that you
can do on the filers and impact
users in a positive
way like this.
And one of my favorite things
that I've seen about Google
is we have the resources
and leadership buy-in,
and there are machine learning
experts who come to Google,
and we built out our
cloud infrastructure
all to the point where at
last, we can deliver something
like this.
And it is truly exhilarating.
There is much more to come, and
I'm grateful to be a part of it
here with you.
All righty, everyone, thank you
very much for your attention.
I appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]